au ciné cette d'elancourt la
fréquentation n'est toujours pas revenue
à la normale en cause la crise sanitaire
et l'instauration du pass sanitaire en
france le 21 juillet dernier
l'établissement classé art et essai a
perdu de nombreux spectateurs et
notamment un public familial sur ses
vacances de la toussaint bon à 30 ans à
35% la par exemple pendant un bon
indicateur c'est des vacances de la
toussaint en sommes en plein dedans les
résultats sont pas du tout ce qu'on
aurait pu l'espérer pour des vacances de
la toussaint normal parce qu'en général
ce sont des vacances comment dirais-je
où on fait le plein dans les cinémas en
tout cas et là on est on est on est
vraiment ça dépend des séances à
dépendre la programmation bien sûr tout
ça joue aussi beaucoup mais on sent bien
que les gens ont du mal à revenir le
ciné 7 d'elancourt va mieux depuis la
rentrée la fréquentation est passée de
moins de 60 % cet été à moins de 30% cet
automne mais les chiffres restent
historiquement bas pour cette salle
ouverte depuis 1975 dans le quartier 17
mar et les blockbusters de ces dernières
semaines n'ont pas booster sa
fréquentation le james bond par exemple
c'est un très bon indicateur on a fait
nous par exemple aussi des 7 je dirais à
un peu plus la moitié de ce qu'on aurait
dû faire normalement en termes d'entrées
avec un film de ce calibre là surtout
qu'il était quand même très attendu on
sait pas un james bond qui va avoir une
carrière la carrière qu'il aurait dû
avoir
normalement avant le début de la crise
sanitaire en 2020 le signer cette
d'elancourt réalisé en moyenne près de
110 mille entrées par an